bonjour aujourd'hui tv 78 vous emmène au
siège de la région ile de france pour
les assises de la réussite scolaire une
journée entièrement consacrée à la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire ça va
commencer juste derrière moi par une
conférence pilotée par james chéron
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france déléguée aux lycées c'est
parti
pour commencer ce tour d'horizon des
assises de la réussite scolaire nous
sommes avec james chéron vice président
de la région ile de france chargée des
lycées bonjour bonjour donc monsieur
chéron comment se passe cette journée
qu'est ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
concrètement c'est une journée de
travail qui permet de rassembler tous
les acteurs qui conjuguent leurs efforts
pour lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire que nous avons une convention
qui a été signée en 2018 redoublent en
2020 il s'agit d'évaluer les termes de
cette convention de regarder comment
nous pouvons aller plus loin donc ça a
commencé par une conférence de
présentation ce matin est là toute la
journée des ateliers qui vont se suivre
quels sont les objectifs alors il ya des
ateliers qui se tiennent au siège du
conseil régional ici à saint-ouen et
puis dans quasiment une trentaine
d'établissements répartis dans
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
pour que les acteurs aux locales les
enseignants les élèves c'est important
que les élèves y travaillent puissent
effectivement sur des thématiques du
particulière échanger construire et puis
il y aura une synthèse en fin de journée
sam avec christoph keller au recteur de
paris et de la région ile-de-france
bonjour bonjour monsieur concrètement
qu'est ce que ça représente le
décrochage scolaire dans la région ile
de france il s'agit de 25000 jeunes qui
sont identifiés comme décrocheurs dans
les faits il y en a 50 % qui sont
véritablement décrocheurs et suggère 50%
il y en a un tiers qu'on a qu'on
n'arrive pas à joindre malgré l'ensemble
des dispositifs qui sont mobilisés une
journée comme celle ci est évidemment
extrêmement importante parce que d'abord
nous sortons d'une période où les gens
ne se voyait pas et rien ne vaut la
présence physique pour se parler pour
resserrer les liens on va justement allé
constater ça sur les ateliers présents
aujourd'hui merci monsieur guerrero
d'assaillants vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes avec raphaël l'article ou
conseillères de la rectrice de
versailles d'un où se tient et se
tiennent des ateliers en ce moment même
qu'est-ce qui vous avez retiré de cette
matinée france un travail vraiment de
mutualisation de bonnes pratiques pour
aider nos jeunes élèves en rupture
scolaire
les aider à trouver une voie à
raccrocher à finalement se projeter dans
un avenir donc vous vous êtes animatrice
pour ses ateliers quel est votre rôle
c'est d'orienter la parole les sujets
c'est non seulement d'orienter la parole
mais surtout de faire qu'on travaille en
synergie entre de multiples services
puisque la difficulté du ste mans de
trouver des solutions pour les élèves en
situation de décrochage scolaire dont
qui ont des parcours en amour atypique
c'est de trouver la bonne porte d'entrée
les ateliers vont donc se poursuivre ici
toute la journée pour rappel les
propositions qui ressortiront de ces
différents groupes de paroles seront
utilisés pour l'élaboration d'un plan
d'actions pluriannuel contre le
décrochage scolaire